when you start thinking about uh bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies given this macro
backdrop are you surprised uh that it's
gone down so much are you surprised that
it hasn't gone down more like what's
your general read if i told you hey
equities are gonna sell off for seven
eight you know ten weeks uh and there's
gonna be all this pain in the public
equity market and bitcoin goes down i
don't know 55 60 percent uh and the
other coins do what they've done like
would you be surprised in either
direction
uh not at all uh correlation is really
high and it just makes sense that it's
it's i'm not surprised at all uh bitcoin
has been
a risk asset um uh basically um
a high beta
risk asset highly correlated with risk
assets since march 2020 and uh since
then it became one and that correlation
has been getting higher and higher
and uh since uh
literally december this year it started
basically trading like equities
like tech
and i think to break that correlation
what the market needs is flows
flows basically inflows or outflows uh
break those correlations um specifically
um that correlation actually has only
broken twice in the last uh in 2022 uh
one was on march uh third two days
before the third
and uh the other day was actually
yesterday you could say it's the same as
today but no not really so it's it's
quite striking that that it trades hand
in hand
uh another thing i'd like to say here is
uh if you look at basically correlation
and how things been evolving
uh bitcoin and basically the crash that
happened because of luna uh bitcoin will
be trading 10 to 15 higher
uh right now if it were not because of
luna and ethereum 20 higher and i think
we will be seeing different price action
what i see right now is actually
something that
it makes me how sad and half very
concerned
seeing that the market trades like it's
like dead it's it's it's not moving so
it's trading more like uh
more like 2018 where there's very little
liquidity and basically you have these
bars all the time because basically any
big order would just make it uh flashing
up or down
um we stopped seeing bart's for a long
time now we are not seeing the bars so
we have that that kind of anemic price
action which on the other hand makes you
think that as soon as we have just a
little
uh aggressive buying from say uh bitcoin
ogs uh some bitcoin whales
we could see one of these scandals where
you have bitcoin up in like seven eight
percent
in a matter of like 60 minutes